have you ever had anything paranormal
happen to you in real life yeah in my
life okay so I'm from South Carolina
and on the south and there's a lot of
things in the South that don't happen
anywhere else you know they just beliefs
that they have things that they do
rituals when I was a kid I used to have
this thing that was sitting on my chest
when I would sleep and it was keeping me
from getting up and I couldn't open my
eyes and I was struggle and I couldn't
breathe very well I was like this is
really like it scared me and I would
fight and struggle I was set up in my
bed and I look around and we'd be like
someone was holding me down I swear and
I tell my mom about it what happened
night after night and and as soon as I
lay down it happened again it's like
holding me and I was like I couldn't
open my eyes it was scaring me so we
talked about what yeah she said it was
it was a thing call it was like a hag it
was called a hag and it would ride you
because your spirit was unsafe yeah yeah
she told me and it was this old woman
living across the street from me and I
would talk about her all the time
because she lived alone and she was
freaky and she never come outside so me
and all my cousin's in the neighborhood
we were afraid of this woman so I think
she's my mom said it's because of your
the way you're thinking about this woman
and she's her spirit is right if this is
just thing that they do and she had
their powers like a witch that's creepy
and I'm sorry I know I know I'm still
dealing with that right I know okay
favorite thing about you go you have a
tiny dog do you have it to protect you
it's a tiny God just a big man with a
tiny dog picture says it all my dog
listen I didn't get the dog in my own
that wasn't my choice but I just feel
like you know I don't need a dog to
protect me I protect my dog that's how I
look at it my dog is a small dog and I
hold my dog and if I see another dog I
pick it up it's you know I'm protecting
my dog that's how I look at do you think
other guys might be overcompensating I
think they got two got two pitbulls you
like pulling on the street you're like
yeah
I will not stop talking until you
subscribe to my YouTube channel that's
right and I could talk a lot seriously
not gonna stop yep still here not going
anywhere I see you don't walk away from
this